have you ever got swung on in practical
jokers
sure people ask that a lot huh yeah um
yeah i almost did look after 10 years
not a lot because we're not really
trying to we're not really trying to
piss people off yeah we're more just
trying to like be muse bewilder confused
like whatever just you know it's more
like that it's more on us but everyone's
while you're going to come across a
person yeah that already is like that in
their normal life and it's just looking
for something yeah so we've all all of
us have been a couple times each in
situations but one time i was at the car
show at the jacob javits center and i
was working for fiat
that was what i was doing and uh they
kept this guy and his girl walked up and
they kept saying like just shadow the
girl like if she turns like don't ever
like stay behind her so she pivoted and
i went behind her it was like the first
second i did it and he literally pushed
her out of the way grabbed me and put
his fist back he said what are you doing
what are you doing right now and her
boyfriend yeah he's a big dude he looked
like he did like ufc and [ __ ] yeah he
like he was ripped yeah but he went from
zero to he literally pushed her out of
the way put his fist up in in in a half
a second all i did and he's like go
ahead go ahead he goes what are you
doing what are you doing and i was in
like a suit jacket and ty i was like
showing the fiat yeah and i looked at
him
and he he literally you know you know
you know there's a difference between
like go ahead bro he was like you saw
like
like he was like that and i just i
didn't want to like antagonize it
anymore you know i defused oh yeah so i
just looked at him and he goes what are
you doing what do you do and i go
i'm just trying to get you guys into a
fiat you know
and i just stayed the course and he's
like yeah what are you don't don't [ __ ]
with me he's like don't you guys and i
just i don't know what you mean man he
goes i'm just i'm just trying to show
you guys this fear
like just soft like that you know and
then like they they took him away and
then they you know and then he didn't
want to hear nothing but uh murray got
slapped in the face hard with a guy's
cell phone like he went like that like
popped him in the face but this guy was
crazy though this guy we were filming at
like a odd lot like an odd job store
like you know what that is oh yeah they
got the rules
yeah yeah yeah yeah it'll like have like
half of an autumn and you're like yes
yeah like and truly and like cereal and
like all that [ __ ] right oh yeah they
got like rescue milk yes
so this guy
is is on his phone and he's a big dude
man he was like six five huge dude and
murray uh is
the guy's talking and they have bins and
i guess the guy's standing and the bin
in front of murray has bras
and like this bin might have no pads you
know but so murray like as he's on the
phone i would like murray takes out the
bra and he like he's like he puts it up
against the guy to like just see and
he's like you're my wife's size and then
you put something out and the guy just
whipped him out and he goes he goes what
are you [ __ ] doing and then the guy i
guess was having a bad day and he just
looked at murray and started to go at
him and then murray ran and he started
chasing murray charging at him screaming
charging at him and swinging at him and
murray's running around the aisles and
the guy's chasing me full public
the restaurant's open the store is open
and then he swung at him and he
clipped him right here right and then
everyone's like all right and then they
asked him to leave and the guy went out
he goes i'm gonna he goes i'm gonna come
back here because i'm leaving i'm gonna
come back here i'm gonna [ __ ] kill
everybody
we had to shut it down immediately
because we didn't know if that was a
true threat yeah he was screaming i'm
gonna come back here i'm gonna kill you
guys i'm coming back and we're like all
right let's just let's just cut this out
right now
for the bras huh yeah but but but but
that's really uncommon oh yeah yeah that
dude i used to hide this isn't like
it's not like your game show but it's
like i remember hiding at my buddy's
house and his hamper and smelling his
[ __ ] mom's bra
when i was a kid man
oh [ __ ]
yeah what are you gonna do kids
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two
options watch one this one or this one